[Musik]
stellen sie sich vor ein goldesel sei zu
ihnen nach hause unterwegs sagen wir ein
moderner goldesel unterbreche ihnen ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen zumindest
für ein jahr 2500 franken jeden monat
jener jungen frau die gleich die türe
öffnen wird ist im mai 2016 genau das
passiert wenn die finanzielle sicherheit
für ein jahr zu besuch ist ein
glückliches leben verspricht davon
handelt dieser film
vor einem jahr legte die schweiz die
volksinitiative für ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen an der urne ab die
initianten jedoch wollten das anliegen
parallel zur initiative auf spielerische
art veranschaulichen
dazu schrieben sie eine lotterie aus an
der sich alle beteiligen konnten
medienwirksam besuchen sie die
glückliche gewinnerin garros zürich
steht plötzlich im fokus
gestern haben wir zu hause gemacht und
halte bezogen
und das heißt für dich du weißt erster
schwitzen gekommen
ja ich habe dank dass ihr wahrscheinlich
dass wir irgendwann werdet foto
haustiere stau und wähle wisse wer oder
was machst du jetzt mit dem und was
passiert wenn wirklich mit dem leben
wenn man ein grundeinkommen erhält ich
warte bis die initianten ihre fragen
gestellt haben und will es von karen
selber erfahren
also ich glaube nicht dass ich etwas
ganz grundlegend wird für andere
vermieter sichert luft mit mir sie
unbedingt schätzung zum zum credo jeder
monat oder also also dass das gefühl es
ist jetzt einfach da was es was es
braucht
aber was ist was mit mir macht das
musste das paar monaten das mit carol
jemand gewonnen hat der die idee
unterstützt freut die initianten
sichtlich das geld für sie wurde mit
einem crowdfunding finanziert
insgesamt haben 511 leute inklusive
carol einbezahlt 7500 haben dann an der
verlosung teilgenommen
carol wurde per zufallsgenerator
ausgewählt eine passendere gewinnerin
hatte man dabei fast nicht finden können
wie sich noch herausstellen wird wie
verändert einen das grundeinkommen macht
das geld faul oder beflügelt ist das
normale leben ist in den meisten fällen
nicht spektakulär und das grundeinkommen
soll ein menschenwürdiges dasein
sicherstellen
ein paar tage nach dem carol ihre ersten
zweieinhalb tausend franken erhalten hat
besuche ich sie wieder der graue alltag
ist da zumindest wettertechnisch deshalb
die banale frage an diesem morgen steht
karl gerne auf mit der sicherheit des
grundeinkommens ließe sich theoretisch
ja ausschlafen aber dann verdient keiner
mehr das nötige geld über drei viertel
der bevölkerung sagten deshalb nein zur
volksinitiative am beispiel von karl
soll die als utopie verstehen eine idee
konkret erfahrbar werden
heute hat carol vor der arbeit einen
kleinen umweg gemacht und will sich
endlich ein neues velo kaufen
das ausstellungs modell ist auch gleich
in der goldigen farbe der kampagne
carol wurde durch ihren gewinn zur ideen
botschafterin für das grundeinkommen
leicht für mich gar nicht verpflichtet
will haben wir das nur schon moment lang
über leitern wir jetzt die offizielle
botschafterin oder so aber ich glaube
tatsächlich ein abkommen glücksspiel
teilt nova und mitfinanziert haben und
den honig und es ist bedingungslos ich
habe jetzt gefühl das sich offiziell
verpflichten aber ab es laut einem
natürlich eine kalte muss es gibt aber
ich glaube nicht dass ich jetzt deshalb
nur das goldex will auch auf das thema
lebt nicht nur durch caron und diesen
film weiter die idee wird im in und
ausland weiter verfolgt und regelmäßig
berichten medien darüber
ich frage nach dem unternehmen mit dem
hauptquartier der initianten dem
ehemaligen hauptsitz der schweizerischen
volksbank in einem alten tresor und sagt
mir daniel häni dass es mit sicherheit
eine zweite abstimmung geben wird ist
das der zweite abstimmung die systeme
schnitt vom tisch und wir werden
natürlich musste erst erlernen und
märkte hat das mit der finanzierung das
harmonie darüber dass braucht das hätte
im handel darüber gebracht dass das ja
gar nicht mehr egal tisch mit dem grund
die commons oder mehr freiheit und das
war dann natürlich eine hoffentlich
schafft mit der nato abstimmen der
bundesrat noch vor 25 milliarden womit
der new yorker was hat ganz konkret
gesellschaft und zwar vom einzelnen
verbessere das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen gott gibt ganz viele
argumente fürs grunde kann man sich ein
zentral ist dass mit der digitalisierung
das heißt dass digitalisierung das heißt
alles wo berechenbar ist wird die
zukunft gar nicht vor der menschenmasse
gemacht war das anders wird von robot
rücken auf algorithmen und das bringt
der mensch und uns als gesellschaft in
trolleys frage was ist denn troller von
menschen zukunft laut einer studie
welche die initianten in auftrag gegeben
haben würden nur zwei prozent ihre rolle
komplett neu definieren und ihren job an
den nagel hängen wenn sie das
grundeinkommen erhalten würden carol
verdient ihr geld bei beo vision mit
nachhaltiger entwicklung zu 70 prozent
wird sie sich ihrer bezahlten arbeit was
ihr netto ungefähr 4000 franken
einbringt und ich finde es wahnsinnig
schön dass ich das kann kombinieren dass
ich so zehn metern verdienen und
gleichzeitig aber aus ich bin dass es
dass es die arbeit braucht bin ich da
mache und es wird mir noch den zinken
grunde kommen mit japan als meister will
die volksinitiative für eine 40 stunden
woche und für sechs wochen ferien für
alle wurden beide ja auch abgelehnt die
schweiz denkt wirtschaftlich und
arbeitet gerne das nächste mal traf ich
gern wieder bei ihr zu hause
sie ist am kisten packen und wird
umziehen was man aber theoretisch mit
dem grundeinkommen macht weiß jeder
irgendwie
entweder gibt es tipps was ich sollte
mitmachen
sie sagt mir dass eine marke oder ich
mir sicher dass leistung und ich möchte
schnecken leisten
die reaktionen hat schon was die anderen
mittel gewonnenen sicherheit anfangen
sollten weiß man oft besser als wenn man
sich dann selber so richtig mit dem
thema befassen muss das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen gäbe es nicht oben drauf
sondern wäre gesicherter bestandteil des
lohnes das neue velo von carol ist nicht
goldig sondern die realität ist halt oft
etwas weniger aufregend auf der brache
in zürich ist heute arbeit spezieller
tag gar als freund präsentiert den
ersten braut container leute haben über
ihn direkt es waren bei bauern aus
indien bestellt man weiß was man von wem
erhält
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die kommen oder möglichkeiten einem
stromer gibt ich halte das mehrere
zimmermanns die ganze arbeit für das
projekt aber es geht 100 andere projekte
besonders mache da war mit der
unendlichen idee so sich freiwillig und
das ist uns und ich glaube es gibt sehr
viele tausend engagiert sind die ganz
verschiedene bereiche grunde komme halt
wirklich die arbeit wird möglich machen
recht das zu drucken geld verlieren man
könnte sich eine kleine auszeit gönnen
oder mit der finanziellen sicherheit des
grundeinkommens auch selbstständig
machen und endlich das arbeiten was man
wirklich möchte unbezahlte arbeit deren
wert durch das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen gesteigert würde wenn
jeder bezahlt seinem hobby nachgehen
könnte würde sich das dann ja irgendwie
aber auch nicht rechnen
auf jeden fall ist das startup von
tobias mit seinem krad container ein
erfolg
[Musik]
und konsumenten und produzenten für
landwirtschaftliche produkte für andere
produkte werden vernetzen mit genannt
werden
direktor dusche vor allem technologische
möglichkeit die ganze digitalisierung
voranschreitet und darum glaube ich dass
das zukunftsmodell ist
[Musik]
die zeiten ändern sich heute sprechen
manche von der vierten industriellen
revolution jener der digitalisierung
beim bundesamt für sozialversicherungen
treffe ich meinen nächsten
interviewpartner 25 milliarden oder
weitere acht prozent mehrwertsteuer
wählen gemäß dem bund um das
grundeinkommen zu finanzieren
er ist mit den initianten seinerzeit
zusammen gesessen und hat die
abstimmungsbotschaft verfasst
aber der entscheidende weg bin
bedingungslose 100 gekommen wie es hier
vorschlagen ist es der satz relativ
hörisch 2500 franken und vorgestellt wie
reagieren blüht dann in der oper zweimal
duftstoffe die widrigen so viel wie
heute urteilt sie schafft wohl nicht auf
die 2.500 onkel und juni bei einer doku
show oder nicht und davon dass diese
frage zu einem glauben dass der vitrine
sowie schaffen gemacht
also soll ich auf meiner seite werde
genau der ist eigentlich wie sich das
nach einer wird die entwickler konkret
aber die leute für die gesamte strecke
dass homo so sage einfach die ganze
ökonomische literatur zeigt dass
münchens und lothar zuvor 1 reagiert und
ich glaube die ganze literatur ihre
liebste was ist ihre persönliche meinung
zur idee möglichst knapp findet das im
grundsatz gut oder nicht
ja es war schön weil ich unterschreibe
ich hoffe nun wir in einem schloss
voller und lebe mir nicht egal wie
fußgänger muss irgendwie zu ihr steht
nach oben das ist arbeit
[Musik]
ein zu großes gesellschaftliches
experiment sei diese volksinitiative
[Musik]
stabilität und langsamer wandel sind
gewünscht
eventuell ist es auch ein
generationenproblem carol ist in die
neue wohnung gezielt und hat heute ihre
eltern zu gast das gesprächsthema landet
wie immer in den letzten monaten schnell
beim grundeinkommen das also ich finde
irgendwie die unterstützung es ist nicht
nur die demo für jede stöhnt die
muttergesellschaft einfach gehofft dass
die finanzflüsse irgendwie so sind dass
am schluss gesellschaft kann schulter
nimmt sondern mehr vorteile wenn das
klingt wie sehen die willensnation oder
nur lagers dass man eine sehen werden
wir den willen aufbringen und den
passiert also wenn man mir der glaube
daran hat dass mir manche wand tätig
sieht das mir sehr gut auch in der
arbeit mit nominiert aber dass mir
grundsätzlich da hätte gewässer sind und
nicht einfach nur bei mir gut aus
glauben und aus unserer gesellschaft
nicht kühl dann hat das auf unsere
individuellen ebene us und von der
bürger perspektiven chancen nicht heute
und nicht morgen zu viel ist unklar
[Musik]
das nächste mal treffe ich gehe bei der
eth in ihrem leben hat sich einiges
geändert
die vision und bin jetzt wieder
studenten also doch denke ich mir die
arbeit an den nagel gehängt
ich warte bis zur ersten pause um eine
brennendste frage zu stellen hat carol
wegen dem grundeinkommen aufgehört zu
arbeiten
also ich habe mir immer man leichter
netz schaffe und ich hoffe es voll aufs
studium konzentrieren
es ist aber nicht so dass er fragen die
kommen nun studieren sondern ich habe
mich angemeldet und merck seit der
studiengang gemacht habe ich mir so
bewerben
dann werden wir gewinnen finanzieren und
finanziere ich so im sinne einer platz
genau das hat ganz klar ein fluss will
ich war entweder einstellen oder so
müsse offen oder ich werde jetzt nach
dem studium nahm schaffen oder die
eltern haben schon damit gerechnet dass
sie die ausbildung mitfinanzieren
das ist jetzt nicht mehr nötig carola
die freiheit das zu machen was sie
möchte
wenn es nach der theorie der initianten
geht nutzt sie der gesellschaft so am
meisten
sie macht in einem vollstudium den
master in entwicklung und zusammenarbeit
zurücklehnen und einfach das geld
bedingungslos ausgeben wird sie sicher
nicht
nun hat natürlich nicht jeder die
gleichen fähigkeiten und möglichkeiten
wie k
aber es soll einen die freiheit geben
nicht mehr sinnlos dem geld nach rennen
zu müssen wäre nicht genau das ein
teilnehmen passend zum glück eine
antwort darauf hat vielleicht bruno frey
er ist politischer ökonom und seit 15
jahren auch glücksforscher bei ihm werfe
ich einen blick in die zukunft und in
das wesen des menschen frauen sei dieser
nicht ich eine völlig auf das bild von
mensch zu mensch zu mensch möchte aktiv
sie aber mehr separat möglichkeit dazu
gehabt und deutsch natürlich kunde komme
schon electric dass man neue
möglichkeiten
viele kaufen also die heute angst vor
der tat nicht bestätigt aus
glücksforscher kartons als glücksfall
weil sie das als ganz wichtiges spiel
aber es müssen ja nicht die jetzige
arbeit cisco yuppies an dass sie zum
beispiel ältere lütz half aber jüngere
lügt oder immigranten
es gibt soviel gut die möglichkeiten wo
man kann es nütze wenn ein kunde kommt
also diese dann gegenüber positiv
gestimmt ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen ja aber nicht jetzt
sondern das ist bis heute zukunft news
corp das ist doch richtig dass man
einmal ein idee lanciert und sich dann
gut überlegt und denn er fährt wenn es
wenn sie tisch und die zwischen niko der
der digitalisierung von der
wirtschaftlichen onyx sowie das
arbeitslosigkeit vergab aber dennis
security die fantasie ist der realität
oft einen schritt voraus
das probejahr mit den bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen neigt sich dem ende zu
nun geht es mit dem geld anscheinend
noch in die ferien
nein ich glaube eigentlich geschaffen
für die nächsten acht monaten nach peru
in amazonas zone kakaobohne kooperative
in peru wird sie für ihr studium in
nachhaltiger entwicklungen daten für
einen schweizer schokoladen produzenten
erfassen
für caro sind kost logis und die spesen
bezahlt sonst arbeitet sie während
diesen praktikum gratis erzielt die
firma später gewinnen dann werden die
bauern in peru am erfolg beteiligt
ein faires geschäftsmodell ich werde
meine generation hat zwar unheimlich
viele möglichkeiten was jetzt aus
bändigen und kurven vermieter betrifft
aber wir sind aber um seine busse
gefordert mit einer extrem dynamische
und unsicheren arbeitsverträgen jetzt
gang hoch und steht natürlich das gründe
kommen kann kann viel sicherheit geht
das grundeinkommen löst keine probleme
sondern lässt sie auftreten so ein
leitspruch der initianten aber ist es
das rezept der zukunft und wie hat das
carol in diesem jahr geholfen
macher und wann wen ich es mir dann
finanzieren und das hat mir wirklich
schon sehr stark erleichtert aber es ist
ganz klar kannst das sind 12 minute und
darum kann ich jetzt auch nicht sagen
wir wir wären mit einer grund gekommen
sondern schon sagen als jahrelanges
grunde kommen bei uns ziemlich toll ist
auch ob ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen das mittel für eine
bessere welt ist ist nicht sicher
es ist eine emotionale und
grundsätzliche frage
die lässt sich nicht mathematisch lösen
deshalb wird dieser film auch nicht mit
einer rechnung auf sondern mit einem
lied von mani matter welches in
anbetracht von sozialer ungleichheit und
finanzieller unsicherheit aktueller ist
denn je
denn was gut geld ging es besser ging es
denn besser was weniger gut geld was
aber nicht geht ohne das denn
weniger gut gehen wo es gut geht
[Musik]